ich verbringe relativ wenig Zeit vor
Computer äh ich
ähm lese lieber oder
geh mit meinem Sohn Fußball spielen oder
verbring meine Zeit anders oder bin im
Studio und hör Musik oder mach Musik
aber wenn ich am Computer bin dann
schreibe ich Mails oder lese Mails ich
gucke auch ab und zu mal auf meine
Homepage
gentleman-usmic de
oder guck auch mal auf Youtube irgendwie
hier und da mir ein Video an und so aber
ich werde dann schnell müde und muss man
die Augen reiben und so und ich Twitter
auch nicht und ich bin auch kein
Facebooker und so bin da eher so ein
bisschen oldschol es gibt zwar eine
Facebookseite von mir aber die hat ein
Fan gemacht die habe gar nicht ich
gemacht so wobei ich die ganz gut finde
irgendwie ich hätte auch nie gedacht
dass ich mal 50.000 Freunde haben würde
wenn ich jetzt eine Geburtstagsfeier
mache dann könn ich die alle gar nicht
einladen ich bin da eher
oldscho